i don't really care very much about the
white house correspondents association
dinner this is a dinner that donald
trump would not attend but that
typically presidents go to and you
schmooze with the people who are
covering your presidency jokes are told
they bring in comedians this year the
comedian was trevor noah i i it's not
really an event i care about and i
thought about covering it live and then
decided i don't even really care about
it i don't think i'm going to cover it
but there are a few interesting moments
from it that i want to go over and um
these are from joe biden now of course
joe biden didn't write this stuff but it
doesn't matter the points that that are
made here are interesting and they're
pretty funny one aspect of this that was
uh sort of controversial was that to go
to this event you had to provide proof
that you were not only double vaccinated
against coven but also boosted and fox
news has a table or at least one table
maybe multiple tables at this event and
of course on air fox news has run
significant anti-vaccine interference
hilariously they were there and joe
biden pointed out one of the great
things about this event is you can look
at the people sitting at the fox news
table know
that regardless of what they're saying
on air they are vaccinated and boosted
check this out we're here to show the
country that we're getting through this
pandemic plus
everyone had to prove
they're fully vaccinated and boosted
so if you're at home watching this
and you're wondering how to do that
just contact your favorite fox news
reporter they're all here
vaccinated and boosted
all of them
and there it cuts to peter ducey one of
the main antagonists of white house
press secretary jenn saki uh i mean
listen it is on the it is on the one
hand a relatively kind of cheap joke and
obvious line
and the people who most need to hear it
probably aren't watching this event but
it is a great reminder that many of the
people
making you question
whether you should go and get the covet
vaccine
by using spurious claims and
non-evidence-based uh uh reporting
they are vaccinated they're vaccinated
and you could say well they're
vaccinated by force because they needed
to in order to well not really i mean
fox news had an option for not being
vaccinated you could choose to test
daily if that's what you wanted to do
but they are making you hesitant to go
and get a vaccine
they are vaccinated they are having a
good time at the white house
correspondence dinner so that was a good
moment uh now for all we know they i
don't know they bought fake vaccine
cards seems risky as a member of a
prominent media outlet to use a fake
vaccination certificate or card to get
into a white house correspondents dinner
so probably not laura ingram by the way
reportedly was there she's been a major
anti-vaxx voice this confirms if indeed
she was there that she's double
vaccinated as well as uh boosted joe
biden with another funny line talking
about the plague and trump i won't spoil
it for you i'll just play it for you the
first time
the president attended this dinner in
six years
it's understandable
we had a horrible plague
followed by two years of coving
i know it's kind of cheesy but i i like
it
just imagine if my predecessor came to
this dinner
this year
now that
would really have been a real coup if
that occurred
i don't know guys i know a lot you know
this is not a policy thing but i i liked
what biden did i thought it was the
exact right sort of tone uh he also and
i mean he is taking on some very serious
issues the next topic he broached was
these text messages where we learned
that mark meadows trump's former chief
of staff as the insurrectious coup
attempt was going on he was texting with
a variety of fox news hosts including
sean hannity everybody was kind of
giving orders and strategizing back and
forth really no uh
no fresh air between the administration
and fox to speak of and biden commented
on that as well take a look
fox news i'm i'm really sorry
your preferred candidate lost the last
election
to make it up to you i'm happy to give
my chief of staff
to you all so he can tell sean hannity
what to say every day
and then uh the camera cutting to fox
reporter john roberts who genuinely
didn't seem to like that
um fox news
really ridiculed during this but
deservedly so i mean mark meadows was
texting sean hannity and telling him
what to say and it's embarrassing and
it's a joke and it's pathetic so really
nicely done i didn't really care for the
sort of uh um actual uh comedians who
did i just i'm not super into it
although trevor noah did have some funny
lines but biden got a bunch of good
stuff there and these are important
issues and to be perfectly frank there
might be people who aren't even aware
about some of these things because they
don't really watch news but they hear
about this as an entertainment event
maybe they watched it maybe they go text
messages hannity mark meadows what's up
with that let me look that up and go wow
trump's chief of staff was telling sean
hannity what to say that's not exactly
fair and balanced news it's not even
really news or reporting anyway it's
just propaganda
so nice job by joe biden doesn't mean
he's doing any better or worse of a job
as president he just did a nice job at
the white house correspondents dinner
which i generally generally speaking
don't care about but uh did enjoy
watching it this time
i hope that you viewers listeners to our
show take your privacy seriously things
i talk about all the time internet
service providers record what you do
online they sell the data it's there for
eternity
big tech companies search engines social
media they're tracking almost everything
you do
they hang on to that information forever
too
i don't let all of these corporations
spy on me i hope you don't either
because avoiding all of it is simple and
affordable today i use atlas vpn to make
myself invisible online one subscription
covers all my devices you don't have to
be a tech person you just install it
once you press a button you forget about
it you enjoy your privacy if you don't
use a vpn a record of your internet
activity will always exist and change
hands tech companies make money off of
you respect your own privacy enough to
install a vpn it's so easy click the
link below to get atlas vpn for 82 off
less than two bucks a month and you'll
get one month for free